i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack
on the united states capitol like all
americans i am outraged by the violence
lawlessness and mayhem i immediately
deployed the national guard
and federal law enforcement to secure
the building
and expel the intruders america is and
must
always be a nation of law and order
the demonstrators who infiltrated the
capital
have defiled the seat of american
democracy
to those who engage in the acts of
violence and destruction
you do not represent our country and to
those who broke the law
you will pay we have just been through
an intense election
and emotions are high but now tempers
must be cooled
and calm restored we must get on
with the business of america my campaign
vigorously pursued every legal avenue
to contest the election results
my only goal was to ensure the integrity
of the vote
in so doing i was fighting to defend
american democracy
i continue to strongly believe that we
must reform our
election laws to verify the identity and
eligibility
of all voters and to ensure faith and
confidence
in all future elections now congress has
certified the results
a new administration will be inaugurated
on january 20th
my focus now turns to ensuring a smooth
orderly and seamless transition of power
this moment calls for healing and
reconciliation
2020 has been a challenging time for our
people
a menacing pandemic has upended the
lives of our citizens
isolated millions in their homes damaged
our economy
and claim countless lives defeating this
pandemic and rebuilding the greatest
economy on earth
will require all of us working together
it will require a renewed emphasis on
the civic values of patriotism
faith charity community and family we
must revitalize the sacred bonds of love
and loyalty that bind us together as one
national family to the citizens of our
country serving as your president has
been
the honor of my lifetime and to all of
my wonderful supporters
i know you are disappointed but i also
want you to know
that our incredible journey is only
just beginning thank you god bless you
and god bless america